PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video
segment we're going
to look at the chain rule.
And specifically we're
going to answer a question
that I've placed on the board.
I want you to find
two values for theta
so that d d theta of
the function cosine
squared theta to
the fourth equals 0.
At this point I should also
point out a few things.
One, theta is a
variable in this case.
And if you haven't
seen it before,
frequently we use it
when we're dealing
with trigonometric functions.
Theta often represents the
variable that measures angle.
So if you haven't
seen theta before,
this is what it looks like.
That's how you say it.
And I'm actually doing the
same things we've done before.
I'm taking the derivative with
respect to the variable theta,
of a function of theta.
The other thing I
want to point out,
which I think we know
already, but just to be sure,
is it that this squared
here, cosine squared theta
to the fourth, means I'm taking
cosine of theta to the fourth
and I'm actually squaring it.
So with that
knowledge I would like
us to use the chain rule to
find two values for theta
where this derivative
is equal to 0.
So I'll give you a
moment to take a stab
at finding the derivative,
setting it equal to 0
and finding some values for
theta that make this equation,
the derivative equal 0.
And we'll come back and then
I'll work it out as well.
OK, so the first thing
we obviously need to do
is be able to take the
derivative of this function
on the left-hand side.
And I should say it's a
little more complicated
than an example you saw in the
lecture, because in the lecture
you were given an example
with just two functions.
So I want to write it a
little differently just
to show very obviously what
the three functions are
we're composing.
So this function
I can rewrite it
as cosine theta to the fourth
does that look like a 4,
there we go and then I
square that whole thing.
That's really what
the function is.
OK?
So we can see what is the
outermost function here?
The outermost function
is actually the quantity
of something squared.
So the outermost
function is x squared.
What's the next function
in, in this composition?
The next function in
is the cosine function.
And then the last function in is
the function taking something,
raising it to the fourth.
So it's very important
you understand
sort of the
composition, which is
the outermost function, which
is the innermost function?
In order to do this chain rule.
Now as you saw in
recitation, you
were given the example dy-- you
had y as as a function of t--
sorry, not in recitation.
In the lecture, you were
given y as a function of t
or a function of
x and then you had
to put one other
variable in the middle.
Here we're going to have a
composition of three functions.
So we need to have two other
things sort of in the middle.
So let's write this out.
First, the outermost function,
we'll call the whole thing y.
So y is equal to x squared
is the outermost function.
So then this whole
thing is x now.
So then we'll write x
is equal to cosine of w.
And then w is equal to
theta to the fourth.
OK.
Again this is what you
saw before in the lecture.
So you write the
outermost function.
And then that
function is a function
of cosine of another
one, cosine of w,
and w is a function of
theta to the fourth.
So if I put all
these back together,
I have theta to the fourth in
here, and then I square that,
and I come back to
the function I wanted.
Now we know from the lecture
what we need to do to find,
essentially, dy/d theta.
That's what we're looking for.
So dy/d theta, you'll see,
you remember from the lecture,
should be dy/dx times
dx/dw times dw/d theta.
So it's slightly
more complicated
than we saw before because
there's one more term.
OK.
So now let's work
out what these are.
Well dy/dx is fairly
straightforward.
dy/dx is just 2x.
And then dx/dw, well
what's the derivative
of the cosine function?
The derivative of
cosine is negative sine.
So this is times negative
sine of w times--
and what's dw/d theta?
So w is the function
theta to the fourth.
So dw/d theta is 4
theta to the third.
Now when you look at
this you should remember,
x we sort of inserted
into the problem
to make the problem easier, and
w we inserted into the problem
to make the problem
easier for us to follow.
So we don't want all
these x's and w's.
We want everything in terms
of, in terms of theta.
But what is w?
Well w is theta to the fourth.
So I can replace that
by theta to the fourth.
And what is x?
x is cosine w.
But w is theta to the fourth.
So x is actually cosine
of theta to the fourth.
OK?
So I get 2 cosine of theta
to the fourth times negative
sine-- w again is theta
to the fourth-- of theta
to the fourth times
4 theta to the third.
Let's make this nicer.
I'll bring the
coefficient and the theta
to the third in front and
this minus sign in front.
I get negative 8 theta to
the third cosine of theta
to fourth sine of
theta to the fourth.
OK, and then the problem
asks to find where
the derivative is equal to 0.
Find two values.
Now why did I ask you
to find two values?
Because one is very easy.
If this thing is set
equal to 0, one value
should stand out
right away for theta
that makes this product 0.
And that is theta equals 0.
So theta equals 0 is
our easiest answer.
So if you didn't
do that, then you
wanted the more
challenging stuff,
you could have done
the other things also.
So what about cosine
theta to the fourth?
If we want a product of
three things to be 0,
then at least one
of them has to be 0.
So I could have set cosine
theta to the fourth equal to 0.
And for what values
of-- an angle
I should just say-- for what
values of theta to the fourth
is this going to be 0?
Well this means that
theta to the fourth
is equal to either maybe pi over
2, or you could add another pi.
OK?
So we could say, well let's
just say that's one example.
Theta to the fourth equals
pi over 2 would work right?
Because cosine of pi
over 2 is equal to 0.
OK?
And so then we could
have said theta is
equal to pi over 2 to the 1/4.
That's another example there.
We could have also done, we
could have added pi to this
and gotten another answer.
But I only asked for two.
So I guess that I'm
allowed to stop there.